les citoyens de saint-lambert se
plaignent depuis des années du bruit des
spectacles du parc jean drapeau à
montréal ce week-end c'est au tour de la
municipalité de la rive-sud de se faire
entendre avec son festival c'est lambert
en fait après quatre heures de cette
wilaya
j'étais partie des la pollution sonore
provient des spectacles mais aussi des
événements sportifs travaux publics et
la circulation j'ai des gens vivent très
bien avec une situation y en a d'autres
qui me disent vous m'avez enlevé mon
havre de paix madame l'oeuvre de paye
est en campagne ou de la musique non
tous les bus des voitures
oui les bruits qui la gare saint-jean de
bruit c'est le voisin à tous les samedis
matin à 5 heures qui remplissent au troc
avec des outils est ce que les citoyens
ont raison de se plaindre ça des effets
réels sur la santé et l'on parle
vraiment d'exposition à long terme les
activités bruyantes peuvent en trop
perturber le sommeil et contribuer aux
maladies cardiovasculaires ce qu'on
estime à montréal c'est que environ deux
tiers des gens sont exposés à des
niveaux de bruit la nuit qui dépassent
les seuils con qu'on connaît comme étant
un problème pour la santé
la plupart des grandes villes dans le
monde sont confrontés au même problème
selon une étude allemande réalisée l'an
dernier les villes où on trouve le plus
de pollution sonore sont le caire les
délits istanbul et paris
al'inverse viennent oslo munich figurent
parmi les villes les moins bruyante au
palmarès des solutions des journées
annuelles sans voiture plus de véhicules
électriques ou davantage de végétation
pour absorber le bruit
après avoir mesuré la pollution sonore
de la circulation de différentes villes
du monde
l'institut national de la recherche
scientifique de son côté a établi que
montréal était beaucoup moins bruyante
que paris et mexico
et si marie laurence de l'aîné radio
canada montréal